the canadian energy company behind the
keystone xl pipeline has pulled the plug
on the project
this comes after president biden
canceled it for environmental reasons
wii xi jiang is at the white house wija
this is a years
old controversy good morning anthony
yeah it is president biden revoked the
pipeline's u.s construction permit on
his first day in office
that was after former president trump
revived the long delay
project that would have delivered some
35 million
gallons of crude oil per day to the u.s
from canada
the biden administration sided with
environmentalists who hailed the
cancellation
as a landmark moment in the effort to
curb the use of fossil fuels
largely blamed for global warming native
american groups also protested the
pipeline concerned about the impact it
would have on tribal lands
republicans and some moderate democrats
opposed mr biden's decision
the top republican on the senate energy
committee john barrasso of wyoming says
by killing the project president biden
has killed thousands of good
paying american jobs the white house has
said it is focused on creating new green
jobs now the pipeline was first
announced back in 2008
and major construction delays caused the
price tag to soar to about 9
billion dollars now officials from
23 states have filed lawsuits to try to
reverse president biden's decision
and resume the work at this point it's
not clear what will happen
since the sponsor pulled its plans tony
thank you very much